for some though they just aren't
comfortable we spoke with one woman
who refused to get the shot and claims
she actually lost her job because of it
so what are your rights if the company
you work for requires the vaccine
sasha loftus joining us now live in the
newsroom with advice from a local
attorney sasha
denise and brian it's a situation many
others could run
into if companies choose to mandate the
kovid 19 vaccine
but if you just don't feel comfortable
getting the shot or you're just not able
to you do
have some options a legal expert i spoke
with
explained we didn't say no we said not
right now
this las vegas woman says she's not
comfortable
getting the covid19 vaccine there were
just a lot of concerns
but they were just not heard
she doesn't want to share her name but
claims she was recently fired
after she refused the shot she says her
employer
cited a mandate making the immunization
a requirement
so what could happen to others in
similar situations
it's for the health and safety local
health care attorney aisha mehdi says
while most aren't implementing covet
vaccine rules so far
private companies do have this power
employers
actually can likely mandate the the
vaccine
as long as it's for the you know it's
for the health and safety
for their for the workplace
but there are exceptions for employees
as long as they're proven
and legitimate they need to make
accommodations for people with
disabilities
or people with religious exceptions so
if you need to pass
but are told to get the injection anyway
it's important to know your rights
and make an informed decision moving
forward
i feel like we should all have our right
to choose or not
choose it
the attorney i spoke with said if an
employee does
choose not to get the vaccine due to a
disability
or a religious affiliation it is that
employee's responsibility to provide
proof that again the disability or the
religious affiliation
are a legitimate reason to not receive
the kovid 19 vaccine
reporting live in the newsroom tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now